good morning believe nation today's
message is don't listen to the haters
over to you logic and hip I was like yo
he's gays yeah like that dude like you
know to me like I just why don't you
like him you know what he can rap he got
a good story his flows of cool for show
I just don't like him though like in it
like so ignorant
it's crazy so like ya years ago you know
them saying when I first got on blogs
and I'd be excited I read comments but
now it's just like there's no point to
recommit
ya don't read the code it I don't read
the cup yeah it's either too it's either
too positive which can lead you to like
the big headed where it's too negative
which could make you try to create music
to get them to stop hating on you it's
like somebody being like yeah he should
rap like this he should rap like that I
don't like the way he raps and then the
person changes up how they rap to try to
you know make that person like them and
then they're like man he and even beat
himself like after your tape so it's
like you can't win you can't win no
matter what you do right so for me I
don't listen to the hate I don't listen
to love too much I just you know take it
all in stride like I love what I do and
as long as I can wake up every day and
feel that I feel like I'm doing right so
now watch this clip back up they get two
things the first is I think you should
be part of the community I think you can
influence the community so that it's a
positive one I think the fact that I'm
involved in the comments I spend time
every single day in the comments and
trying to give feedback and say thank
you I think that matters I think it
brings you guys closer to me I think it
brings you closer to the cause that
we're all about I think it leads to a
much more positive environment I compare
my channel to a lot of other channels
that are of my size or bigger and the
amount of hate that are on those
channels compared to mine
I've seen it a lot less online and I
think it's directly proportionate to the
content I'm talking about but also me
and my team being involved in the
comments and so I don't I don't
necessarily agree with as an artist you
want to stand above everybody else and
just not pay attention to them and just
do your own thing I think there's
definitely a tangible benefit to being
involved in the community
you are then serving - the second thing
is I think you have to draw a fine line
between when you're gonna listen to your
audience and when you're gonna do your
own thing and not to be influenced too
much by something that doesn't feel
right to you I think there's a balance
so I think I think listening to the
audience and being yourself can create
something really amazing so I look at my
channel as an example most of the
content that comes up is from requests
is from you guys right I have had the
good fortune to learn a whole bunch of
things that I didn't even know about
because you guys put it on my radar
you know logic I've never heard of logic
before making this video and maybe
that's maybe rap is a big blind spot for
me but now I've been introduced to
somebody else where I may be able to
learn something from that wouldn't have
happened if I wasn't listening to you
guys at the same time though you have to
do things that are comfortable to you
that are authentic to you that feel
right to you you know all the logic
videos that we can pull from the ones
that I pull are the ones that I learn
from the ones that I find interesting
and that hopefully you find interesting
as well where if you came on and hated
it on my channel and said Evan you know
believe is stupid or you know I don't
like the sound of your voice or you know
whatever I'm not changing that like I
can't change the sound of our voice I'm
still gonna put out content that I
believe in that I love but I think there
definitely is a balance to be able to be
struck that can create a really
wonderful world where you are listening
to the people who are consuming your
content and at the same time being
authentic and true and and still being a
visionary to yourself of where you want
to go so that's my take I'm Krista
figure what you guys think so the
question today today is how involved
should you be with your community and
listening to them what do you think
leave in the comments below I'll join
the discussion today shadow goes to
Steve so then from bumper apps Steve
thank you so much you're picking up a
copy of my book it really means a lot to
me and for those of you who want to
change add a shadow' in their future
video make sure they pick up a copy of
the book and email in your seat so we
can keep track thank you guys so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events fess up
away expresso give me go